فاجنر الاسم الذي ارتبط بساحات المعارك
والتدخلات العسكريه الروسيه حول العالم
فبالرغم من الكابوس الذي تعيشوه نتيجه
التراجع الكبير لها في اوكرانيا في
الاسابيع الاخيره وتوقف المجموعه عن ارسال
مرتزقتها الى مناطق نفوذها الا ان هذه
القوه التي تشعب ميدانها العسكري ليشمل
سوريا وليبيا ودول افريقيا العده واخيرا
اوكرانيا
اصبحت اشبه بدوله عسكريه مستقله بمواردها
الخاصه لتعمل لصالح روسيا في الخارج
واصبح حتى تدخل في تحالفات مع دول اخرى
وتبرم معهم صفقات لشراء الاسلحه بل وصل
بها الامر الى توظيف قاده عسكريين سابقين
كمستشارين لها
وبين ما يستمر سباق تسلح على قدم وساق بين
القوات الروسيه والاوكرانيه يستمر الوجه
الاخر للجيش الروسي في تغذيه هذا السباق
لصالح موسكو حيث استلمت باجر شحنه من
الاسلحه من كوريا الشماليه شملت صواريخ
وقذائف للمساعده في تعزيز موقف القوات
الروسيه في اوكرانيا في مؤشرنا على اتساع
نطاق الدوري تلك المجموعه في هذا الصراع
التهديدات التي تشكلها المجموعه طالت
البيت الابيض والذي وصف المجموعه بانها في
طريقها لان تصبح منافسا للجيش الروسي
متعهدا بفرض مزيد من العقوبات عليها لما
تشكل من تهديدات للمنطقه ككل كما فرض
قيودا جديده على صديرات التكنولوجيا
لمجموعه فاجنر في محاوله لمنع الامدادات
عنها
التقدير الامريكي يشير الى ان كميه العتاد
التي سلمتها كوريا الشماليه لن تغير من
وقائع المعركه في اوكرانيا
وفي الوقت نفسه عبر مسؤولون امريكيون عن
طريقهم من ان كوريا الشماليه تعتزم تسليما
المزيد من العتاد العسكري
بالرغم من نفي مالك شركه فاجنر اتهام
واشنطن ووصفه بانه ثرثره وتكهلان سلطان
العربيه